[Música]
hablamos ahora de salud en directo
américa de france a 24 ya está conmigo
lista en el estudio más romeros sala
porque hoy es el día de la lucha contra
el cáncer marc cómo nos afecta esta
enfermedad pues nos afecta de muchísimas
maneras raúl es la segunda causa de
muertes en todo el mundo y también en el
continente americano se calcula que son
unos 10 millones de los fallecimientos
que hubo en 2020 según cifras de la
organización mundial de la salud los
países donde más muertes de cáncer se
han recontado también según cifras de la
ms son por ejemplo haití cuba jamaica
también uruguay en estos países superan
los 100 las 125 muertes por cada 100.000
habitantes les siguen argentina y
bolivia en cambio colombia y méjico
vemos que tienen alrededor de unas 80
muertes por cada 100.000 habitantes sin
embargo las muertes no son la única
manera de calcular cómo afecta esta
enfermedad a las sociedades americanas
cuando vemos los años vividos con
discapacidad que provoca el cáncer vemos
como los países norteamericanos canadá
eeuu superan con creces al resto de la
región en estas cifras y en estos
gráficos como siempre raúl influye la
capacidad de cada país primero de
detectar el cáncer y luego también de
tratarlo y de tratar de curarlo así es
marc pero le quiero preguntar entonces
si estos sus casos de cáncer pueden ser
evitables pues así y es algo que
discutiremos ahora más adelante también
con nuestras voces expertas lo más
lamentable es que haya alrededor de un
30 y un 50 por ciento de cánceres que
pueden ser evitables hay muchos factores
que influyen a la hora de desarrollar
esta enfermedad pero hay varios que se
pueden prevenir la oim es también
calcula esa cifra es el porcentaje
primero tratando de eliminar al máximo
los factores de riesgo como fumar el
consumo excesivo de alcohol la mala
alimentación y luego también reforzando
los sistemas de prevención como decíamos
por ejemplo tratando de detectarlos lo
más tempranamente posible así es más
pues gracias entonces por esta
introducción pero por supuesto le pidió
que se quede conmigo porque nuestra
segunda mitad del día vamos a tratar
este tema los dos juntos
[Música]
y como lo veníamos adelantando hoy es el
día internacional de la lucha contra el
cáncer todo tipo de cáncer ya tenemos la
introducción con nuestra periodista
experta en salud más romeros sala y
ahora quiero entonces saludar a nuestra
segunda invitada del día y es carolina
weisner ella es directora general del
instituto nacional de cancerología de
colombia gracias a la doctora por estar
con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 y le pregunto cómo podemos
prevenir entonces que aumenten los casos
de cáncer
bueno pues la prevención ha sido un
capítulo muy particular que en el cual
ha hecho énfasis la organización mundial
de la salud puesto que las políticas
públicas son las que tienen un impacto
real en la prevención del cáncer
entonces esto ha sido claro por ejemplo
para el caso del tabaco en donde el
incremento del impuesto ha disminuido la
riesgo de que los jóvenes se inicien en
el consumo del tabaco la reducción en el
consumo del alcohol todo lo que
significa evitar la exposición a ciertas
infecciones como es el virus del
papiloma humano el 'helicobacter pylori'
en donde tenemos que promover adecuadas
condiciones de la limitación el agua las
condiciones del aire es decir todo lo
que tiene que ver con el ambiente y ya
los comportamientos más individuales que
tienen que ver con estos hábitos de
editar el trabajo el consumo de alcohol
y por supuesto participar en los
programas de estabilización las personas
que no tienen síntomas hacerse los
exámenes para conocer su riesgo de
cáncer en caso y poder hacer un
tratamiento oportuno doctora pues
tomamos notas de todas estas
recomendaciones porque de hecho el
cáncer se prevé que vaya aumentando en
los próximos años para 2040 se proyecta
que haya casi 30 millones de casos
diagnosticados y 16,4 millones de
muertes es un crecimiento muy
significativo respecto a las cifras que
tenemos hoy en día porque aumentarán a
tanto los casos de cáncer en el futuro a
qué se debe este crecimiento
bueno en la incidencia de cáncer es
decir el incremento en el número de
casos nuevos está en relación directa
con el índice de desarrollo humano es
decir que la humanidad en la medida que
vivimos más aumentamos la expectativa de
vida y hay un mayor porcentaje de por
encima de 65 años esto incrementa la
probabilidad
y mutaciones en la célula es decir que
el envejecimiento de la población es una
condición que incrementa el número de
casos de cáncer sumado a esto a los
factores de riesgo
así es doctora pues también le quiero
preguntar entonces si los sistemas de
salud en américa latina están preparados
para hacer frente a este crecimiento de
los casos de cáncer teniendo en cuenta
pues la precariedad de algunos países de
nuestra región respecto a nuestros
centros de salud con en comparación
evidentemente con países desarrollados
como europa eeuu
bueno podríamos decir que los países
desarrollados han tenido la más larga
experiencia para enfrentar las
patologías como el cáncer entonces
tienen desarrollados programas para la
detección temprana de una manera mucho
más articulada entre los diferentes
niveles de atención podemos decir que en
la región
de las américas en la parte sur
hemos estado digamos una larga
trayectoria histórica para enfrentar las
enfermedades agudas y transmisibles pero
todavía no tenemos la suficiente
experiencia para atender las
enfermedades crónicas que implican una
lógica diferente para la atención en
salud entonces esto es un reto no
solamente en lo que significa organizar
programas de detección de ventanas por
los efectos los que están creciendo mama
de próstata sino también tienen centros
especializados para ofrecer a los
pacientes las diferentes servicios que
requieren la atención del paciente
cáncer en las diferentes modalidades de
su presentación que son infraestructuras
complejas y de alto costo entonces hemos
avanzado pero todavía estas brechas muy
largas para garantizar una calidad de
datos
claro de hecho es importante recordar
también esos altos costos no es algo que
podemos preparar desde ya que los
gobiernos pueden preparar desde ya para
tratar de evitar que sea algo más grave
en el futuro entremos llenar un tema un
poquito más concreto los cánceres
hereditarios son una parte un porcentaje
importante de los cánceres que se pueden
desarrollar a lo largo de la vida qué
avances podemos esperar en el futuro
para tratar y también para tratar de
evitar este tipo de enfermedad
bueno los cánceres hereditarios
están más o menos entre el 5 al 10 por
ciento de todos los cánceres esto
significa que cuando una persona tiene
diagnóstico del cáncer a una edad
relativamente temprana es asumimos que
sea antes de los 50 años podría ser que
esta persona tiene una mutación de un
gen que ha sido heredada heredada y por
eso resulta indispensable
posible identificar esta agrupación en
el resto de los miembros de la familia
una de las mayores
trayectorias ha sido la identificación
de mrc a uno o dos que implica que las
mujeres tienen un riesgo muy alto de
desarrollar cáncer de mama en el grupo
familiar y por esto se ofrece una
cirugía reductora del riesgo como pueden
ser la mastectomía otros cannes otros
tipos de cáncer se ofrecen para las que
tienen el riesgo de tener cáncer de
ovario no se ofrece la autonomía
profiláctica o para los casos de las
familias que tienen poliposis
adenomatosa familiar
cuando se identifica la mutación del gen
se unen de manera profiláctica hacerlas
colectores pero pues esta situación
solamente es para un grupo pues está en
muy reducido del total de cánceres que
suceden
hablando de esta enfermedad digamos o
tan dolorosa y también emocionalmente
fuerte en doctora le pregunto si es
posible erradicar la
bueno dado que el cáncer va más o menos
yendo en enfermedades pues es un tema
bastante complejo hablar de la
erradicación pero si podríamos decir que
ya la organización mundial de la salud
por ejemplo ha propuesto el cáncer de
cuello uterino se puede eliminar
erradicar porque ha sido suficientemente
estudiada su fisiología y la manera de
intervenir es así como se ha propuesto
que se puede eliminar si hacemos la
estrategia 90 70 90 es decir que el 90
por ciento de todas las niñas que
cumplen 15 años haya recibido la vacuna
contra el cáncer de pinter y no una
contra el virus del papiloma humano que
el 70 por ciento de las mujeres al menos
a los 35 años se han ganado una prueba
para saber su riesgo en cáncer y hayan
recibido el tratamiento en caso de
necesitarlo y las mujeres a las que
tienes identifica enfermedades pre no
clásicas el 90% de las mujeres en el
mundo reciben tratamiento así se planea
que en el largo plazo lo podemos
erradicar y por supuesto la vacunación y
la cta también permite eliminar pero
tendremos que vivir
justamente de eso le quería hacer
mi siguiente pregunta no estaba hablando
del cáncer de cuello uterino provocado
por el virus del papiloma humano en su
mayor parte no hay vacunas contra
algunas de las infecciones que pueden
desarrollar cáncer después en el futuro
mirando hacia adelante qué avances
podemos ver también en estas en estas
vacunas porque además recordemos por
ejemplo que eso podría suponer una gran
diferencia en países de ingresos bajos y
de ingresos medios donde estos cánceres
provocados por infecciones suponen el 30
por ciento frente a un 13 por ciento de
la media global entonces habrá buenas
noticias mirando hacia adelante en el
desarrollo de futuras vacunas
bueno en este momento tenemos
disponibles dos vacunas profilácticas
que es la vacuna del df h sin embargo
resulta preocupante que cuando
alcanzamos ese desarrollo tecnológico
siempre hay una
resistencia a la vacuna creo que la
pandemia cover nos ha mostrado el
beneficio absoluto de disponer de
vacunas para el control de la enfermedad
esperamos que las personas se va a poner
y la otra que está
la vacuna contra la hepatitis b que
previene el cáncer hepático ya teniendo
en consideración que se conoce de manera
mucho más específica la biología
tumoral y el desarrollo de la
inmunoterapia están en estudio
muchísimas vacunas terapéuticas que
ofrecen unas alternativas muy
interesantes para tratar de las
enfermedades en malinas doctora el lema
de este año es cerrar la brecha de
atención le preguntó entonces qué brecha
son las que existen y qué pasos se deben
tomar para poder eliminarlas
bueno teniendo en consideración que el
cáncer conjunto de patologías malignas
implica contar con una infraestructura
compleja y de alto costo
entonces disminuir las brechas significa
que todos los pacientes con cáncer
puedan tener acceso a estas tecnologías
diagnósticas y terapéuticas
entonces si se ha visto unas diferencias
grandes entre de acuerdo con los
sistemas de salud aquellos países que
han logrado acceso universal a los
pacientes los pacientes pueden acceder a
todos los servicios inclusive el cuidado
paliativo pero hay grandes diferencias
regionales en respecto a la posibilidad
de tener acceso y sobre todo una
oportunidad a los beneficios que nos ha
alcanzado la ciencia y la técnica
queríamos cerrar con una última
reflexión se dice mucho y hay víctimas y
familiares que dicen que el término de
batalla contra el cáncer puede ser
negativo para las personas que pierden
precisamente contra esa enfermedad como
experta me gustaría simplemente saber
cuál es su opinión al respecto de estos
términos que los medios usamos cada día
sí creo que ese es el lenguaje ha sido
dado por muchos pacientes y
escritores es el lenguaje de la guerra
sin duda alguna esta es una enfermedad
que nosotros ahora tenemos que
comprender de una manera mucho más
integral y estoy también convencida que
el lenguaje lo debemos modificar puesto
que las personas que han sobrevivido al
cáncer y que han tenido esta experiencia
se transforman espiritual y de muchas
maneras su sensibilidad y esto es el
lenguaje yo estoy segura
así una mitad más comprensiva
doctora pues gracias por estar con
nosotros nuevamente en este espacio de
france 24 directo américa para hablar
del día internacional de la lucha contra
el cáncer gracias doctora por su tiempo
un abrazo
pues mar estábamos como conversando con
la doctora carolina 20 en reductora
directora general del instituto nacional
de cancerología de colombia para hablar
sobre esta enfermedad en todo el mundo
nosotros continuamos en derecho
americano